hey youtubers is Charlie so we may have
learned about rhaegar targaryen coming
on Game of Thrones most of us thought
that he was going to show up eventually
but now it seems like we actually have
some more evidence so this can be
explanation of what's going on so the
big news is that the lead singer of I
see stars Devin Oliver announced that he
was basically doing some Game of Thrones
he's like I may or may not have film
some Game of Thrones in this post here
and you don't really tease something in
that way if you haven't done it so
everybody is thinking now that he would
be a great Rhaegar Targaryen just
because one he's a singer like Rhaegar
was and two he has like the fair
features that regards described as
having like he wasn't like Robert
Baratheon like this hulking giant beast
of a man so like all throughout season
six we got flashbacks to Robert's
rebellion it makes sense that they would
use more flashbacks to create context
for the scenes that are happening during
season 7 many of those adding context to
Jon Snow's parentage so we learned who
his mother was last season but they
muffled the audio when Liana was
explaining things to Ned just kind of
like letting you know as the viewer that
they really only want you to know that
Lyanna stark was his mother that was the
whole point of this big scene here so
any other explanations would be saved
for other scenes so anybody that's read
the books or you've been following the
theories even if you haven't read the
books you know that people believe that
Rhaegar Targaryen is Jon Snow's father
just all evidence points to that
Martin's been building towards that
reveal it's kind of like this Romeo and
Juliet story that's told in flashbacks
on the TV show but there's a little more
evidence for it in the books just
because the show has to cut out a lot of
the books so why would it be important
that Jon Snow's father was a Targaryen
in the heir to the Iron Throne well the
big reason would be is if you wanted to
get rid of Cersei who's the Queen now
and you needed another legitimate
candidate that had an important name
that the people loved so Varys talked a
lot about Daenerys when he was
explaining that to Tyrion during season
five but now we have Jon Snow he is also
a Targaryen so he could use one of two
really respected names but he'd have an
actual legitimate claim if his father
were Rhaegar now it's not quite so
simple as that but you can understand
the TV show would compress a lot of that
so you have like all the people that
love John snow already just because he's
John snow that's what the little bear
speech was all about I don't care what
his name is he's the king of the north
so you have a lot of people like that
but that's not everybody there's still
people that will not support him if they
don't think he's legitimate they won't
back his claim in the other lords who
he's trying to gain support from would
probably want him to cement an alliance
with a marriage and that's really where
you get into the idea of lineage
legitimacy when it comes to the nobles
of the kingdom supporting a marriage so
you got to be popular that's one part of
the equation Jon Snow already very
popular too you have to have the name so
the second part is a little bit harder
to prove that it would make sense if Jon
Snow is going to eventually make a play
for the Iron Throne they would create
context in the show to explain why
that's possible
like right now Daenerys seems like she's
the only person who's going to be making
a play for the Iron Throne but then were
you to learn about Jon Snow's father on
the TV show forget the theories just
imagine the TV show reveal that then
you'd be like oh wait a minute
if he's the son of the heir to the Iron
Throne then you start doing the calculus
in your head and it gets way more
interesting so at the beginning of the
season you have Cersei verse Daenerys
you have Jon Snow up in the north trying
to get ready for the White Walkers and
then in the background you have the idea
of Jon Snow's lineage the true heir of
the Iron Throne that they won't really
need to explain until you need to get
the support of the south because that'd
be like the easiest way for Jon Snow to
get the entire kingdom to support him
and defend against the White Walkers
because that's really the endgame like
you need to get everybody on your side
when White Walkers make it south of the
wall in the best way to do that would be
if you were king of the Seven Kingdoms
you could just order everyone to send
their troops so there's just a number of
reasons why it would be important that
they finally reveal who Jon Snow's
father is so however big any flashback
scenes are remains to be seen there are
only going to be seven episodes so I'm
not expecting as many flashback scenes
as we got during season six but there
are only a couple big ones that we need
to know now one we need tourney at
Harrenhal too we need battle at the
Trident so they could do any number of
Rhaegar flashbacks that they want but
let me know in the comments do you think
that this
is actually playing Raigarh in a
flashback or he just happens to have
white hair and has a cameo somewhere
it's just that there aren't that many
people that have white hair in a Song of
Ice and Fire
and are not Targaryen it is extremely
rare but other really cool things that
are happening right now for those of you
that are big book readers they released
enhanced editions in the iTunes Store so
they have a bunch of illustrations
they're actually really cool so if
you're reading the books right now and
you want like an even cooler Edition you
have to buy them in the iTunes stores I
think they're exclusive to iTunes but no
worries I'm actually going to make the
giveaway for iTunes gift cards so all
you have to do to enter the giveaway is
just be a subscriber leave a comment on
this video there's more cool Game of
Thrones stuff happening next week that I
can't talk about yet but there's cool
stuff so just stay tuned for that and
Westworld is premiering on HBO Sunday
night I will do a video for that first
episode it's supposed to be crazy
hardcore it's more of like a sci-fi spin
on a big game of Thrones type universe
so I recommend you check it out it's
cool story but it's supposed to be crazy
pilot episode while you guys wait for my
next video you can click here to watch
the season 7 teaser trailer again you
can click here for my first Luke Cage
video thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you